so I like to create dispatches from
ecstatic realms I'm interested in
offering people a sense of a lived
experience I want people to have an
experience of knowledge by acquaintance
when they encounter my work not just
knowledge by experience it's like the
painter Rothko who said that people who
weep before his paintings are having the
same kind of ecstatic weeping that he
had when he painted the painting in
other words what the artist wants to do
is transmit his inner life and so people
often ask me about these ecstatic realms
what is the felt experience in the
realms of the timeless what does it feel
like when you are in the mytho poetic
right the Greeks make the distinction
between Chronos and Kairos Chronos is
mechanized cognition live by the clock
tethered at a time of Kairos is the
mythopoetic and the timeless and one of
the qualities of the timeless one of the
one of the characteristics of these
domains is heightened qualitative
intensity you are in the midst of it
compelled into a kind of immersion or an
aesthetic contemplation you barely
understand nor even desire there's
always an element of surprise when all
of a sudden you have star gated to the
sacred and the moving from the ordinary
world into the realm of the ecstatic is
very much again a kind of star gating
that is akin to a reverse Dali shot of
extended duration now if you
seen a reversed dollar shot in cinema
it's meant to show a threshold crossing
of awareness when a character is going
from one state of consciousness to
another something is shifting how do you
show that visually well the reverse
dolly shot does it v zooming in with the
camera while the dolly that's holding
the camera is pulling away at the same
time which creates this feeling of like
roof-like there is a shift from one mode
to another mode and this new mode of
course is the mode of transformation the
mode of The Ecstatic the mode of
heightened qualitative intensity it's
akin to hitting the system it's akin to
hitting the sustain pedal on the piano
right it's akin to the moment in which
the strumming guitar kicks into gear
when the song grabs you it takes
hold of you and mapping these
transitions from modes of be from Kronos
to Kairos and then mapping the
mythopoetic terrain is the purpose for
my being and the reason for my work I
want to to map those new domains I want
to map the pathways to those new domains
I want to communicate through an
experience of knowledge by acquaintance
I want to make you essentially directly
acquainted with the transition from the
transactional to the transcendence I
want a map for you the felt experience
of the shift from Kronos to Kairos from
the everyday to the mytho poetic from
the ordinary to the archetypal this is
my resume d'etre but I saw your stoy ID
para transmitted ecomony cod beaver SEO
not meant to give you the download so to
speak and also to give myself the
download for I am also a member of my
own audience I too like to be a witness
to these reflections and these
transmissions thereafter for they show
me who I am when I'm not there these
videos show me who I am when I'm not
there they allow me to witness myself
when the inner critic has shifted on
when I'm in dance right when I'm in the
dance I get to see myself in the
ecstatic and that my friends because a
somatic memories these videos scene
afterwards are integration for me
they are cognitive repattern being
digital transmissions they are glimpses
of what was essentially an open heart
surgery of the psyche which is every
time you submit and you have an
experience of the realms beyond so
yeah that's why I do what I do I want to
give words to the undescribable
I want to map being affable I want to
provide an actual taste right an actual
download of the mythopoetic and The
Ecstatic I want to show you directly the
felt experience of the moments that take
our breath away the transitory enchanted
moments that come to define our lives
the experiences of all experiences of
such perceptual expansion such mental
vastness that your models of the
world have to make room for a new
accommodation right baseline reality
dissolves in the new reality starts to
emerge and it's pixelated wake one is
pregnant with realization and vision
earring and imagination and humility and
Wow so
I hope that you have
received me tree and I am so grateful
for the opportunity to show myself and
point the way my way because everybody
can find their own way but my way and if
you find resonance with that and if you
know what it's like to Stargate to the
mythic and if you two have had moments
that take your breath away and if you
two have been inside that reverse dolly
shot moment of extended duration where
it's like whoa I've slipped streamed
into the sacred and Here I am and I'm
here again and if Jamie wheel says I
remember what I forgot that's where we
heal my friends that's where
you